[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let me start there with mike florio by
the way
pro football talk in november 60 million
page views almost 16 million unique
visitors biggest month since september
of 2019
pat yourself on the back mike florio
well done
hey i'm just glad that uh you know the
audience out there that claim that
they're not
going to pay any attention to football
this year has come around now that the
election is over
that's all i'm saying about that all
right uh thank you
it's good it's football's back and we've
we've held the season together
not that i've had anything to do with it
or you had anything to do with it but
the nfl has held the season together
this far
let's see what happens in december could
will fuller sue his doctor
well if the facts as he alleges them
are true perhaps but
dan look i i'm amazed because i've been
covering the nfl
on a daily basis for 20 years now the
nfl has never caught a cheater
via its ped policy the nfl has only
caught guys
who unknowingly took a substance that
was on the banned list because
it was spiked into something that they
bought at gnc
or the doctor told them this or someone
told them that they have resources
available
if they have any questions you call the
union they have hotlines
they have a list of what you can and
can't use from a drug standpoint a
supplement standpoint
even if he's telling the truth i don't
know why you would rely upon
your doctor when all you have to do is
call your agent or call your union
and i just always enter these
conversations
assuming that this is another example of
someone who has chosen to not say
i cheated and you caught me because
under the
under the version that we get and that
we've gotten for the last 20 years other
than julie edelman
julian edelman whose response was i
don't know what happened
every other guy has said he's taken some
sort of a spiked substance or he didn't
know and
no one has ever come out and said hey
you caught me
yeah i forgot edelman hey i don't know
what happened here like
i've used that excuse with my parents
growing up i don't know what happened
here
yeah why is there a dent in the car i
don't i don't i don't know what happened
here
i don't know what to tell you that's the
ultimate
i don't know what to tell you yeah
because you have nothing good to tell me
is the nfl doing a good job with coven
i'm amazed that we've gotten through 12
weeks with all games played except one
pending tomorrow but
you know dan at some point when
something goes wrong
the knee-jerk reaction for the league is
to say it's a failure of a team or a
player or whoever to follow the
protocols
it's never a bad protocol and we're
getting closer and closer to the point
where the rubber is going to meet the
road on whether or not the protocols are
effective because as these numbers go
up in the wake of thanksgiving and the
nfl
wisely shut down all facilities monday
and tuesday with limited exceptions
because they understand players and
coaches had people in from out of town
for thanksgiving now i still can't
reconcile that with playing games
on sunday and monday that's a different
issue altogether but they realize it's
getting worse
fine at some point though they have to
flip the switch
on the home market bubble at some point
the only way
to keep this thing on track is to make
sure everyone is under the same roof
all the time 24 7 no intermingling with
people who aren't being tested all the
time
constant concern for physical distancing
and mask wearing and being careful and
prudent
that's how they're going to hold it
together because it feels like it's
teetering and it felt like it was
teetering this weekend there were rumors
among teams among executives with teams
that the nfl was just going to pull the
plug on week 12 and make all of week 12
week 18. now the nfl said
there were no such discussions but
that's just an example of how bad it's
gotten
and there's no reason to think it's
going to get any better over the next
five weeks
i just wonder and i'm not saying that uh
you know their justice is
arbitrary but you know with what
happened in denver felt like they were
really going to punish the broncos but
you guys created this
now you deal with this uh baltimore i
was told by
a league source last night john harbaugh
is a hypocrite
because he's claiming to be a victim but
they created the scenario where
you know the steelers should be the ones
really upset not the ravens
so how do you look at those situations
well
going into the season i thought the nfl
was going to try
dan to balance
case by case situation by situation when
and if the lack of
sufficient healthy offensive lime and
the lack of sufficient healthy
quarterbacks any position group
decimated by
players on the covet 19 reserve list
whether that would justify
postponement of games when october
rolled around the nfl decided
screw it our approach is we got 256
boxes to check
we are going to check every box and get
every game
in and if someone has a competitive
disadvantage
you don't have enough offensive linemen
too bad you don't have enough healthy
quarterbacks
too bad you don't have enough defensive
backs too bad
you have to play with what you have you
have to plan your practice squad
accordingly they got 53 spots on the
active roster
16 practice squad players any or all of
whom can be called up up to 90 minutes
before kickoff
you have to deal with it and that i've
been told over and over again is the
difference between baltimore and denver
baltimore had an uncontained outbreak
that they were trying to get
under control that the league was trying
to get under control and they didn't
feel that it was safe to bring the team
together they didn't feel it was safe to
proceed with the game
to put guys on a plane guys on a bus
guys in the locker room guys on the
sideline
because they weren't sure that the
outbreak had been contained that's why
the ravens
got three postponements and to the
extent that the ravens bear blame for
this and clearly they do their strength
and conditioning coach
was typhoid mary for this outbreak but
you know dan last week
the league knew there was an outbreak
they let the ravens gather at their
facility in practice on monday
they knew there was an outbreak they
knew there were positives from sunday
they knew there were positives for
monday
they let the ravens practice on tuesday
until they finally pulled the plug
because they wanted to get the game in
thursday night so
this isn't a situation where only the
ravens are to blame the league instead
of
immediately pulling the plug on the
thanksgiving night game which could have
potentially salvaged
sunday they let them practice monday and
tuesday because they wanted to get the
thursday night game in so
you know that i think that the the
danger of placing blame on anyone in
these instances
ignores the fact that that in most of
them there's
plenty of blame to go around andrew
brandt had a
tweet earlier today of course former
front office
front office executive and he said if
we're not going to postpone
or cancel a game given what happened in
baltimore like can you give me a
scenario where you think that we would
actually have a game that's uh forfeited
or cancelled
well forfeit's tough to do you know
there's never been a forfeit in the 101
year history of the national football
league and it also creates a financial
can of worms because
when they crafted the agreements that
allowed the 2020 season to precede dan
nothing was contained in there about
what would happen with player
game checks in the event of a forfeit i
think the nfl is avoiding that
possibility for that reason and other
reasons they don't want to go down the
path
of declaring a winner and a loser
because we're in a pandemic
stuff is going to happen when do you
start drawing the lines between forfeit
and postponement
and you know this possibility of week 18
you've been talking about it i've been
talking about it we've talked about it
i'm sure when i've been on with you in
the past
yesterday it finally crystallized for me
what the problem is with week 18.
if you made raven steelers the first
game that gets kicked
to week what do you do if the ravens or
the steelers have an issue
the rest of the way with any of their
games what if the bills have an outbreak
next week and the sunday night game
between pittsburgh and buffalo has to
get postponed
which one do you play which one do you
not play
oh well raven steelers was first that's
the one that gets played but what if
bills steelers has more impact on more
teams
to determine who gets to the playoffs
and who doesn't and and so i think
the reason they haven't pulled the rip
cord on week 18
is they understand that once you
burn that spot for two teams you are
operating on a tightrope
on a windy day with no net is mike
florio pro football talk
co-host you can see him every morning on
peacock with
chris sims also you can go to his
website there because everybody else is
uh the 49ers are without a home so now
they're playing in arizona
like okay like there's so much of this
where we go
yeah okay that's fine niners don't get
to play two games at home they're
playing in arizona
is that fair it's not like they're
losing a home field advantage now
yeah i mean really yeah they don't have
any fans at any of the games at levi's
stadium
when the schedule came out in may dan
one of the first things i did
was i looked at the schedules of the
california teams and i looked at other
teams reasonably close by to see
if one of these teams couldn't play at
home
where would there be conflicts where
would they be home games going on at the
same time
and the first thing that jumped out at
me san francisco arizona they never play
a game
at home on the same day i think they've
always known
that arizona was the alternative for san
francisco if they couldn't play games
there and it finally happened
i'm fascinated by the idea and i think
it's moving in this direction they're
going to practice in arizona
they now have a bubble the 49ers have a
bubble they're going to have everybody
in a hotel
in arizona away from their families for
five weeks
i'm still trying to find out what kind
of negotiations happened with the union
because you're talking about
a dramatic change in work conditions for
these players these players are now
24 7 employees they can't be with their
families they can't go home they're on a
business
trip indefinitely what did they do by
way of talking to the union to get this
approved because dan i think collective
bargaining is one of the big reasons why
we don't have 32 teams in a bubble
because you're talking about a major ask
for a player to say tell your family
goodbye
you'll see them in early january you
can't go home you can't see them
that's not what these guys signed up for
you imagine if the super bowl was in
california this year
so it wouldn't be yeah it would be in
arizona
uh great to talk to you congrats on the
success with the website there mike we
appreciate your time as always
all right dan good being with you as
always all right that's mike florio pro
football talk